[Musique]
que faites vous si le président de la
république décide de ne pas aller à la
primaire de se présenter permettez-moi
d'abord de vous dire que ce serait un
coup de force inacceptable donc
l'intéressé ne se relèverait pas parler
d'un quelles que soient les périodes et
quelles que soient les moments doit être
dirigée si c'est le cas et donc il a
rappelé que tout le monde devait être à
son poste pour une candidature de
françois hollande est ce que ce matin
vous avez des informations précises ou
pas non je n'ai aucune information
simplement françois hollande a dit qu'il
donnerait sa démission mi décembre lors
d'un déplacement en tunisie manuel valls
a rencontré le président béji caïd
essebsi un nom que va écorché le 1er mai
si le mot que vient de prononcer manuel
valls veut dire pénis en dialecte
tunisien
il avait fait un lapsus hier vous avez
dit dans les cinq années qui viennent le
dire dans les cinq mois qui viennent
vous lui prêtez encore une chance alors
d'être candidats les deux et d'être
président de la république
je pense qu'il est décrédibilisé décès
est pas quand on est condamné a oscillé
entre des socialistes qui ont échoué
lamentablement et des revenants qui ont
gouverné ensemble pendant dix ans car
françois fillon pardonnez moi est un
revenant
je suis extrêmement vigilant je dirais
pas que j'ai confiance
nicolas sarkozy me disais je fais c'est
balladur avec jean luc mélenchon
je voudrais ensuite pouvoir me tourner
vers lui allait discuter de ce que nous
voulons faire ensemble
vous pourriez vous ranger derrière lui
je voudrais surtout qu'ils viennent dans
la primaire par les autres candidats
sont pas des perdreaux de l'année non
plus les six ans et fillon se retrouve
face à un gp où presque personne
n'imagine ce scénario par thierry solère
l'organisateur de la primaire à droite
et les lieutenants de chaque candidat
sont allés au parti socialiste prendre
des conseils chez arnaud montebourg qui
était lui de l'initiateur de la paraguay
se rencontrer le chiffre de dix mille ça
vient d'où oui parce que nous avions eu
dix mille bureaux de vote en 2011 un mot
pour les badauds qui ont été donnés deux
euros mais votre caisse qui est née
cette idée c'est on avait avec 31 des
farouches y de 8000 et au sein du bureau
politique avant la valise est censé à ma
jupe et même jean françois copé et dans
le comité politique il est pas remplie
un françois fillon
mais il faut qu'il y ait tout le monde
sait bien je trouve que françois villon
à résoudre ce calcul de bureaux de vote
n'a pas été confiée à mon avis aux
bonnes personnes dans son équipe je
dédie à à brice hortefeux par exemple
qu'il se faisait entre guillemets avoir
sur la répartition ses bureaux de vote
et je crois qu'on n'a pas su dans
l'équipe sarkozy imposer une norme
marais vous c'est un casus belli est ce
que ça signifie qu'à ce stade vous
n'excluez pas vous même si le projet
reste en l'état une candidature je
n'exclus rien je ne ferme aucune porte
[Musique]